how handy is transformations on the
number plate you might recall
transformations are about changing a
shape in a way it makes the shape still
similar now there are three different
transformations that we learnt about the
union can anyone remember what they were
so much hasn't said anything
so doesn't said anything yet one could
someone tell me a way to transform a
shape or figure British lines sliding
okay sliding is good
we had a fancy name for sliding does it
remember what it was starts with at each
place very good translation okay someone
give you the libretto rotation okay sir
rotation that's our fancy what's like a
vocal good way you can take more tanks
yeah it's your time or speed busy but
fun okay I've got one more to go
okay reflection again that's the fancy
word you could either say quickly flip
or mirror very good I'm gonna go to the
flip because it's just joy okay
wonderful
yeah yeah so you mean you may like to
just drop these down be ready just to
remember
so now we're gonna do is we're gonna do
these with more precision because when
you've got a number plane like these
guys you know not just like oh it's an
arrow and it's kind of tall I know
exactly where all of the points on the
our art so I can do this with super
precision it's going to be great okay so
the first thing you need to do in your
book underneath these three devices
let's all do question one together okay
let's all do question one together you
can see the first thing you'll do is
actually just start with what they've
given you so you need a set of axes look
at how far it goes up and down and then
this shape that's on there this arrow
you need to draw it on if you've got
another color got my beginning soon you
can see things apart probably advisable
to use a pen for the axes and a pencil
for the rest of it because you might
make a mistake then that's fine okay
so can I give you a couple minutes draw
this diagram this first of all draw it
together
question one I'll come around miss and I
will have a look and make sure you're on
the right track use a ruler please all
right wonderful so you got your diagram
and it looks awesome
I'm sure okay if you use the rule on all
that kind of thing or it's on its way to
looking awesome now let's have a look at
what they're asking us to do it says
copying translate we have done the copy
bit then what you have to translate we
are sliding so this thing is going to
say the same size it's going to stay
facing the same way and I'm gonna sort
of move it around like this it says six
units left and two units down okay so
now if you have a look at where your
shape is right they said six left and
two down so my advice to you is take it
point by point okay so let's just be
alphabetical I'm gonna start at a you
can see I'll do it in I'll do it okay so
you can see there's a right so I'm going
to move it what did they say again six
tuna left and two
down okay so I'm gonna go one two three
four five six to the left one two down
now if I just come back momentarily you
might recall that when you do
translations whatever kind you do you
start with the original and then the new
thing is called can you see the word
they use there starts with an i starts
with an i it's called the image right so
it's like when you look in the mirror
there's you and then there's the image
in the mirror okay so this image is
called a - B - C - each one corresponds
to its original okay so therefore I'm
gonna label this guy a - right and I'm
gonna go around a logical way make sure
I don't miss any so here's B now right 1
2 3 4 5 6 and then what ya tree down 1 2
so there is B - right and you can see if
I want I can join that up and I can go
all the way around let's see it looks
like I'm gonna have C - over here you
can join that up and then you can
complete your shapes you see how that
works
can you go ahead and finish your diagram
and do the translation off you guys
we're done that's it
tada you've got a beautiful error and it
here has been translated slid over that
way everything's great